Haven't done one of these episodes in a while...
Last time on True Fear, I talked about the
fight for Independence!
Or at least…
the fight that happened when me and my friend
went to go see the Independence Day movie
that sucked, where some pretty creepy stuff
ended up going down, so if you want to screen
that episode, I’ll leave a link and it’s
really up to you though if you want to watch
it.
So my other creepy movie theater story happened
10 years ago when I went to go see the movie
1408.
I loved 1408.
I think it’s one of the most underrated
Stephen King movies.
If you aren’t familiar with the film, it’s
based off of a short story about an author
who writes about haunted places, and someone
challenges him to stay in this supposedly
haunted hotel room in New York City.
He tries to stay overnight in the room, but
soon finds himself unable to distinguish hallucinations
from reality, and unable to escape room 1408.
I went to go see this movie with my two friends…
let’s just call them Billy and Bobby.
Because those were their actual names.
As I mentioned, this movie came out in 2007,
so we were in 7th grade at the time.
We had all just gotten to the age where we
were old enough to have our own cell phones,
so my parents would just drop me off at the
movies with my Sanyo PCS Vision Phone, and
I could call to get picked up afterwards.
That evening, we had gotten to the theater
a bit late, so we were just walking in right
as the movie was starting.
About 30 minutes in or something is the part
of the movie where the protagonist, uhh let’s
just call him Mike Enslin, because that’s
his actual name, is getting settled in the
hotel room when things start to go weird.
Now I know jump scares tend to get a lot of
hate these days, but I really like them when
they’re done right, and 1408 does an excellent
job of making the viewer put their guard down
before a --
So there are a bunch of jump scares in this
movie that involve the alarm clock, phone,
and other appliances around the hotel room.
Remember how I said that we walked into the
movie right as it was starting?
Well, it turns out that we missed the silence
your phones reminder, and Billy had forgotten
to turn his off before we sat down.
So sure enough, at the exact moment of the
phone jump scare in the movie, Billy’s phone
goes off at a startling volume.
And I can’t even begin to describe the terror
of that moment.
The jump scare in the movie would have been
enough by itself.
The volume of Billy’s phone ringing would
have been enough by itself.
But the fact that they happened at the exact
same time, made it feel for that one moment,
like the haunts of the movie were in the seats
with us.
This was also before the days where there
were a lot of ringtone options, so Billy had
just had a generic analog phone ringtone that
almost matched the sound of the phone in 1408.
It only took us a moment to figure out what
had happened, but that one moment was a moment
of panic, and it was enough to put us on edge
for the rest of the 112 minute runtime.
There’s not much else to this story, you
can look at it as a coincidence or you can
look at it as something deeper, but one thing
you’re definitely going to want to look
at is the next episode of True Fear, where
Cynder is going to be filling in, and filling
you in on how a lunatic attacked her on the
bus.
If you’ve got any scary stories about the
movies, please do share them with us in the
comments.
We’d love to hear them.
If this story has spooked you out of going
to the movies, maybe you'd rather stay home
for some CZsWorld & Chill.
If that's the case you gotta pick up this
merch which I'll leave a link to in the description.
Remember to subscribe to CZsWorld for new
horrors every week, ring that deathbell for
notifications and I’ll see you in the next
one.
Assuming we --